[Music]
you know up to about 20 years ago canada
had a party possibly the only one in the
world that was literally called the
progressive conservative party and it
existed as the center-right party under
most recently mulroney and the
short-lived kim campbell i think was
prime minister for three months and
never actually got to speak in
parliament unfortunately
and then imploded and then there's about
20 years in which various figures ending
up with stephen harper who became prime
minister of canada for for nine years
until defeated by a liberal justin
trudeau essentially reshaped canadian
conservatism and i think it's more than
symbolic that he took the word
progressive
out of the conservative party name in
canada and actually managed to win one
way or another three elections in a row
the question i have for you bim is was
someone like stephen harper in an
anglophone parliamentary system
taking the right message about
conservatism that if you try and mix
being progressive
and being conservative you'll just end
up in a mush and it's much better to
just stick to something that actually
tries to avoid that question of
progressiveness in the first place is
that the right lesson to take from the
canadian example would you say
that's a fascinating question um
how shall i answer it
there are a couple of things here the
first
is that i would argue and i don't want
to compare david cameron and stephen
harper because i don't know i know much
more about david cameron than i know
about stephen harper but
there was something about cameron's
leadership of the conservative party
that was trying to do that
progressive conservatism
and i think that
if david cameron were doing a speech
around 2008 2009 somewhere like this he
may well have used the terms you know
i'm a progressive and i'm a conservative
yeah
and the question is why has that run out
of road
and i think fundamentally
it's because
if you take economic liberalism and
social liberalism
the
economic liberalism
appeared to be
less successful than we had thought in
the 80s and 90s
and what that necessitated was
a slightly balancing over to a more a
more balanced mixed economy
and so once that happened there were
there was then a chance
to get the support because of your
economic policies there was a chance to
get the support of certain people who
were also socially conservative so
almost to meet them halfway
the party then became a little bit more
socially conservative i use as a as an
example of this
the um
the gay marriage legislation put through
forward by david cameron which i wasn't
in parliament at the time but i would
have supported uh if you think how
controversial that was at the time
everybody's forgotten now but it was an
incredibly controversial
thing to do
but ultimately was put through
imagine what the debate would be like
today if it had happened then i just
think it would be a lot more raw
so
that is the that's the way i think about
that question just to stop the back of
that just because it shows how social
conservatism and i think political
conservatism of other sorts can change
it's worth noting that in the united
kingdom which you know overall is one i
think the most more socially liberal
countries within europe
although um gay rights uh essentially
you know the right for gay men in
particular to meet each other um freely
without um you know kind of any illegal
persecution began to end in 1967 in
england and wales it wasn't actually
until 1980 that that law was ended in
scotland and yet today in terms of
social liberalism at least in terms of
the political elite scotland is at least
perceived as being much more liberal
than large parts of the english
establishment so these things can change
even within a generation i want to bring
in deidre i know it's dying to come in
but the key question also deirdre is
conservatism and progressivism is that
actually philosophically compatible can
we bring the two together
well it you know
these are always matters of what you
mean
and of course if you're a
classical continental style conservative
bloodland and the church
no
of course they aren't
um it it
by the way i'm a
trans
i'm a trans woman i transitioned in 1995
and it strikes me very forcibly
that that um the
uk is startlingly
non-progressive
on transitions
it it had to be dragged kicking and
screaming over the line
um you know the the uh
but
these things are i i think we all agree
come in
to use the old um
marxist argument in waves of opposition
and
then re-opposition and then
re-opposition and i i think uh i i i
think paul
is right
to point to the resentment
of the english working class
and scottish working class for that
matter
um
that
created
this
chance for the conservatives to to to
seize again
the um
the banner of
social conservativism
i imagine it'll it'll reverse itself
soon and we'll go on
bouncing back and forth forever
can we turn to you paul um i mean you've
been very critical for obvious reasons
uh in terms of your uh your critique of
post-capitalism in the title of your
last book of neo-liberalism which in
economic terms has been associated with
conservatism for some decades now
do you think that that's
essentially a way of removing some of
what has been progressive about
conservatism in the past
first of all i would say that um
neoliberalism was not really the
property of conservatism it may have
been indeed initiated by conservatives
but if you think about the it's high
point the goldilocks era schroeder
clinton and blen were the people uh
running neoliberalism
that's right
so where does the progressiveness go in
i'm almost
i went as a left-wing activist on early
i'm a straight white man i went to early
gay pride demos when they were
demonstrations uh you i i
was on the one where the where the where
the miners turned up you know the one
that's depicted in the movie pride but
before that in the late 70s gay pride
was a it was it was like sort of
it was a political statement if you can
create a new consensus in which the left
and right basically agree over the
marketization of
of of the economy
issues that were once highly
systemically challenging like gay rights
like even for example national scottish
nationalism or catalan nationalism can
now be absorbed into
what we think of progressiveness can be
accepted i think by mainstream
conservatives the one curveball i want
to throw into this though is i i think
when we look at modern con today's
conservatives we're actually still
talking um about with the exception of
the gop in america we're talking about
parties that are actually on the classic
political science matrix of left right
so liberal conservative they're quite
centuries
the difference is to their right there
is a radicalization
this is not the making of boris johnson
it's not boris johnson who made nigel
farage it's not boris johnson who who
caused 20 of voters in my town
well first of all to vote for the bmp
which is a fascist party then for ukip
and then to switch to the conservatives
that was in that was in their
political culture
independence of the conservative party
concerning party is where they've ended
up so
we can't lump everything on to the
institutions of parties something deep
is going on in the right of plebeian
politics well can we stick stick with
you paul then but move the question on
also
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you